high school musical the musical the
series best title ever um i think it
just describes
how the show is it's very
tongue-in-cheek fun but i play zach roy
who is the rival school theater teacher
um
and you know miss jen and i used to date
in high school so there's a bit of
you know yeah it's like do we hate each
other do we love each other this kind of
i love that kind of thing um yeah that's
called tension
it is yeah it's electric yeah um but
it's it's fun man i'm not gonna lie
though i
just even watching that clip i i can't
watch myself so i'm the same way i don't
like watching myself
there's certain things i don't mind
watching like like certain dance
performances i'll be like i'll watch it
i'm like you know what yeah good job
that was that was all right
but for the most part 90 of the time
yeah i don't watch myself just let it go
let the art go yeah you know what's
funny i don't watch me when i'm doing my
songs
but i do watch kalioke's because it's
covers yeah so there's something
different about that i don't know i'm a
detached somehow i don't know but
it's it's weird yeah so i i you saw me i
crawled behind the crowd
i am with you i can't look at the screen
i feel so uncomfortable
but i think that's kind of cool because
then you don't change yourself i think
if you want people watch themselves too
much you change yourself because you
feel like you find the things that you
don't like about yourself
but that might be what other people love
about you that you know yeah anyway you
do you
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help